eGPU’s have become more and more popular
in recent years, and many people are now considering
buying a MacBook Pro with base graphics and
adding an eGPU with something like a Vega
64 or Radeon 7 graphics card instead of buying
a fully specced-out 8-core Vega 20 model.
The idea is that you’ll get a portable MacBook
to use on the go while getting a ton of extra
graphics performance at home with the ability
to upgrade the graphics card down the line.
The concept sounds great, but we’ve discovered
that in a lot of cases, you really don’t
gain that much performance, and in some cases,
you actually lose performance.
And we’ve also found a way for you to test
your current machine to see if you’ll benefit
from an eGPU or not, so stick around until
the end to find out how.
In this video, we tested both the $400 Vega
64 and the $700 Radeon 7 graphics cards using
the $300 Razer Core X GPU enclosure, which
is in our opinion, the best and most reliable
enclosure you can currently buy for the cash.
We’ll leave links to all of these down in
the description.
Let’s get started with Geekbench 4’s graphics
test.
As you can see, the eGPU’s offer a decent
jump in raw graphics performance over the
Vega 20 graphics in the MacBook Pro, and the
Radeon 7 actually surpasses the performance
of the iMac, which is nice, but it should
be getting a lot more than that, seeing as
using this card in a Windows PC actually gets
you around 210,000 points.
The score is much lower for two reasons, first
of all, eGPU’s send data through Thunderbolt
3, so there’s a lot of efficiency loss,
and reason number 2 is that even though we’re
on macOS 10.14.5, the drivers for the card
are still not fully optimized.
Now let’s move onto the Unigine Heaven gaming
benchmark, we actually start to see the Radeon
7 shine, with over twice as much FPS as the
Vega 20 graphics, so if you’re a gamer,
an eGPU will actually help a lot.
One thing I do want to mention is for the
best results you should always use an external
display plugged directly into the eGPU and
force each program to use it by right-clicking
on the app in the applications folder, clicking
get info and selecting prefer eGPU.
Now moving onto some Final Cut Pro video editing
tests, we ran the standard BruceX benchmark,
which basically just uses 100% graphics, and
saw a really good performance boost over the
MacBook Pro by itself, but for some reason,
the Vega 64 actually did just as well.
We’ll explain why we think this is happening
in just a minute.
Now onto stabilizing a 20-second clip, both
eGPU’s perform exactly the same, and only
a bit faster than the MacBook Pro by itself.
And here is where it gets interesting, this
test is exporting a 5-minute clip of standard
h.264 4K footage, which is basically what
most YouTubers are working with every day.
We actually got much slower times with the
eGPUs, and interestingly, the Vega 64 was
faster than the Radeon 7.
So why the heck is the MacBook Pro faster
by itself?
Well, this type project is already really
easy and efficient for the standard MacBook
because of the hardware decoding and encoding
with QuickSync.
Using an eGPU adds a lot of extra steps and
bottlenecks, requiring the data to go from
the CPU to the thunderbolt controller, through
the Thunderbolt cable and then to the graphics
card to be rendered, then back again to the
CPU to be encoded instead of doing everything
inside of the MacBook Pro with no bottlenecks.
For the previous tests like Unigine Heaven
and BruceX, the graphics is the bottleneck,
so those scenarios can use an eGPU to its
full potential.
Before we move on to some more difficult tasks,
like RED R3D and Canon RAW, I need
to give a shoutout to our Sponsor, Skillshare.
Now some users are starting to move onto HEVC
where the MacBook Pro by itself performs better
than the Vega 48 iMac!
That’s because it’s packing Apple’s
T2 chip that has hardware HEVC encoding.
The reason the eGPUs are slower is the same
as before, and once again, the Radeon 7 is
slightly slower than Vega 64.
Now let’s move onto some more advanced editing,
4.5K R3D RAW, which is heavily dependant on
the processor and not the graphics.
Here, we see that the iMac is the fastest
because it has the most powerful processor,
with the MacBook Pro trailing behind with
or without an eGPU.
As you can see in this screenshot, the CPU
is completely maxed out and the eGPU is basically
doing nothing because it has to wait on the
CPU to process the RAW footage.
And now onto C200 RAW footage, which uses
a ton of graphics power, and here, we finally
see the eGPU’s speeding things up, and that’s
because the MacBook Pro by itself was limited
by the Vega 20 graphics.
In fact, you’ll see in this screenshot that
even the Radeon 7 graphics was the limiting
factor, since it was 100% maxed out at full
usage while the CPU was chilling at just 39%
usage.
And again, the iMac was faster because it
doesn’t have to deal with Thunderbolt 3
inefficiencies.
So these were obviously video editing tests,
which don’t use just the graphics, so if
you’re doing something like gaming or some
other task that really uses tons of graphics
power, you’re gonna see speed boosts similar
to the BruceX and Unigine Heaven results we
got earlier.
But to be honest, the bump in speed isn’t
really what we were expecting, especially
since the Vega 48 should be much slower than
even the Vega 64, but it isn’t because of
eGPU efficiency loss.
Even worse, the Radeon 7 performed basically
the same as the Vega 64, and it costs about
$300 more than the Vega 64.
This honestly makes us think that Apple took
the easy route of repurposing the Vega 64
drivers for the Radeon 7 since both the benchmarks
and real-world results are so similar while
the same GPU performs about 50% better in
Windows.
Hopefully Apple will finally have decent drivers
for it when macOS Catalina comes out in September.
But for now, we recommend just buying the
Vega 64 and saving $300 if you’re gonna
use it in an eGPU.
If you’re a video editor using Final Cut
Pro, do not buy an eGPU for your MacBook Pro
unless you’re editing very specific video
formats like C200 RAW that are very graphics
intensive.
And even then, the performance isn’t that
much better considering you have to deal with
the little glitches and issues that come with
using an eGPU, like your display randomly
going blackout of nowhere.
Other apps like Resolve and Premiere Pro may
see more gains from an eGPU, and we’re currently
testing that and will post a video on the
Max Yuryev channel, so make sure to subscribe
there.
If you’re wondering if you’ll benefit
from using an eGPU, we have a simple test
you can run to find out if you’ll gain performance
or not.
Download iStat Menus 6 from bjango.com and
while you’re doing your specific graphical
work like 3D animation, for example, click
on the CPU icon in the taskbar, and if the
blue processor bar in the graphics card section
is fully maxed out while the CPU is not really
being used much, that means you’ll benefit
from an eGPU.
If both the CPU and GPU usage are nearly maxed
out, that means that if you buy an eGPU, your
processor will become the bottleneck and you
might not see much performance gains.
But if your CPU is maxed out and your graphics
is not being used much, you won’t gain anything
at all from an eGPU.
Now how about for other Macs?
Should you buy an eGPU for your iMac?
Probably not.
Because of the Thunderbolt cable inefficiencies,
you probably won’t see much gains at all,
and you’ll probably lose performance if
you’re using an iMac Pro.
Now Mac Mini users will benefit the most from
an eGPU because it doesn’t come with a dedicated
graphics chip at all, so you kind of have
to get an eGPU for heavy graphics work.
So there you have it, that’s why most people
shouldn’t buy an eGPU for the 2019 MacBook
Pro.
If you enjoyed the video, tap like and click
the circle above to subscribe, and make sure
to check out one of those two videos right
there.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!